A qué hora se espera que llegue a
Georgia y con qué fuerza a este huracán
Ian Bueno ya degradado actualmente
tropical
como muy bien dices tormenta tropical
Pues a lo largo de la noche y del
Viernes ya se sentirán los efectos
porque antes de que llegue al centro de
la tormenta Carolina del Sur veremos
como aumenta el viento aumenta el oleaje
Y eso hará que se puedan producir esas
inundaciones costeras y el centro de la
tormenta podría tocar tierra este
próximo viernes en la tarde noche eso
todavía hay un poco de incertidumbre
porque tiene que meterse en las aguas
del Atlántico ahora acaba de abandonar
el centro de la tormenta la Florida de
estar en contacto con el piso cuando ya
esté en el Atlántico se verá mejor Hacia
dónde irá es muy probable que alcance la
costa de Carolina del sur este viernes
en la tarde noche pero ya desde hoy van
a sentir como el viento va más la lluvia
y esas inundaciones costeras que siempre
es el mayor problema porque es donde más
se va a sentir los efectos de Ian Y ante
esto le pregunto al ver cómo se prepara
la gente allá que paramiento digamos por
parte de la población hay este tipo de
miedo
Sí hay miedo de hecho después de lo que
ha ocurrido en Florida ahora la mirada
está puesta en esos estados están ya en
estado de emergencia Eso es bueno Porque
será más fácil que el Gobierno Federal
pueda mandarles ayuda está Florida
Georgia las dos carolinas y Virginia
bajo estado de emergencia en Florida
ahora la recuperación va a ser lenta se
tiene que recuperar el suministro
eléctrico más de dos millones y medio
están a oscuras no hay agua en muchas
zonas el impacto sobre las carolinas no
tiene que ser tan grave porque
hablaremos de una tormenta tropical
quizás huracán categoría uno pero no es
un categoría 4 casi 5 que impactaba
sobre flores Así que los efectos van a
ser bastante diferentes va a ser un
episodio importante pero no esperemos
que sea tan grave como en el sur de
Florida Albert estamos evidentemente
digamos ante una crisis climática global
digamos que esta crisis climática ha
fortalecido estos fenómenos naturales
han golpeado con más fuerza
territorios por cuenta la crisis
Sí el cambio climático sabemos que una
de las consecuencias es que el mundo
está más caliente tanto el aire como la
superficie de los océanos como los
océanos y de allí sacan la energía los
ciclones de modo que si en los próximos
años seguimos viendo que el planeta Se
está calentando va a ser habitual que
los huracanes que se formen tengan más
energía en su gasolina no de aquí que si
en los próximos años no sabremos si
habrá más o menos eso no lo podemos
saber pero sí que los que se formen
tendrán más energía disponible como le
ha ocurrido a Ian cuando estaba en el
Caribe se encontró un agua muy caliente
88 89 grados Fahrenheit eso es gasolina
para él por eso se intensificó tanto
antes de llegar a Cuba y a la Florida en
los próximos años fenómenos como este
van a ser habituales pero lo importante
en cuanto Los Huracanes es la
trayectoria Así que siempre tenemos que
esperar a que se formen para ver Hacia
dónde van si se queda en medio del agua
no son una amenaza cuando toca en tierra
Los problemas son evidentes